so a lot of insiders have been talking
about both for a while now and very
recently about one particular scene of
Deadpool 3 no Insider has Straight Up
come out and said what this scene is
about but it's widely believed to be
about the ending or about the post
credit scene now we know Deadpool 3 is
going to directly link to and also set
up in a really big way Avengers Secret
Wars in fact Deadpool 3 is where it's
all really supposed to go down and the
new Multiverse Avengers team is going to
start to be established and now recently
the past week a lot of insiders have
been teasing this scene again and I
think we have figured out what this
scene is based off of everything that we
know about Deadpool 3 so far and
everything that we know is going to
happen in secret Wars it seems pretty
obvious now and the scene does involve
of course Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
Deadpool and Spider-Man specifically
Toby Maguire Spider-Man and we've 've
been hearing since Spider-Man no way
home that he is indeed going to be
returning to the MCU at some point in
time as we got further along into the
Multiverse Saga reports started to come
out stating that he's going to be in
Avengers Secret Wars which came as
little to no surprise because he was in
no way home it would be foolish not to
bring him and Andrew Garfield back to
reunite not only with Tom Holland but
with the original X-Men some of the
Fantastic Four members the new Avengers
everyone basically in Avengers Secret
Wars so what could this scene involving
Deadpool Wolverine and Toby Maguire be
about we'll break down what we know in
this video and also Toby Maguire is
mentioned but this might not be the same
exact variant of Toby Maguire Spider-Man
that we saw in no way home and we'll
explain in this video but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Marvel and MCU news we're also giving
away a PS5 and Xbox series X and more
we'll talk more about that at the end of
the video so several months ago on
September 10th of 2023 Daniel rpk K The
Insider posted the logo of Deadpool 3
with a caption Pizza Time and a lot of
people were kind of confused this is
obviously a reference to Toby Maguire's
Spider-Man Saiyan Pizza time but what
does it have to do with Deadpool 3 we
know that there are going to be a lot of
cameos in Deadpool 3 is Toby Maguire
Spider-Man one of them it wasn't really
clear it was just hinted at however he
Then followed up with a follow-up
comment stating this will be clear when
you see the ending of Deadpool 3 then a
few days ago Insider Alex Perez from the
cosmic circus on January 23rd posted a
gif of a scene from Spider-Man 2 where
Peter Parker gets fired from his job
delivering the pizzas then more came
Lizzy Hill from the cosmic Circus the
editor and chief responded with a gift
of Hugh Jackman laughing then The
Insider cryptic HD quality posted a gift
of a man basically falling indicating
that it's basically something pretty big
and possibly pretty shocking then Alex
Perez posted a gif of Deadpool being
shocked stating I really wasn't
expecting it then to top it all off Alex
Perez quoted Daniel RP's post the one
that said Pizza Time back in September
stating the way I'm still reeling so
clearly there is a source out there
close to the studio who knows inside
information that a lot of these insiders
also know because it appears that
several insiders now know kind of the
same thing now although no Insider has
come out and basically talked about the
scene other than pizza time we can kind
of deduce based off of what we know what
the scene could be about and I believe
that this scene could be the true start
of the Multiverse Avengers team just
think about it for a second we know a
lot of what is going to happen in
Avengers Secret Wars it's not exactly a
secret at this point in time the same
thing kind of goes for Deadpool 3 Shan
Levy the director even came out and said
at some point in time very publicly that
they are not going to ignore the old
previous Fox franchises with the X-Men
basically stating straight up yeah
they're going to be cameos it's a
Multiverse film and we are going to see
the previous Fox X-Men and it's the
Multiverse Saga and it's Avengers Secret
Wars a Multiverse film we know that the
X-Men are going to show up we know that
some variants of characters that we
might not have seen are going to show up
and we hope other characters return like
maybe Ben Affleck's Daredevil maybe some
older version of the Hulk maybe the old
Punisher maybe the old Fantastic Four
members with Jessica Alba anything is
really possible even seeing Chris Evans
come back as Captain America and the
Human Torch from the Fantastic four this
is basically what secret Wars is
supposed to be about heroes from
different universes coming together to
save the Multiverse against K the
conquer and any variants of King that
there might be and we know that they're
going to have to work together now
there's a rumor that has been going
around for a while stating that Deadpool
3 is going to explore many different
universes and the TVA is going to kind
of start to bring a bunch of Heroes
together to go up against Kang that is
most likely what we are going to see
here and I believe that this Pizza Time
scene is most likely referring to Hugh
Jackman and Deadpool wanting to go and
get Toby Maguire Spider-Man to help them
another report that has been going
around is that Hugh Jackman Deadpool
Spider-Man our Spider-Man Tom Holland
but also Toby Maguire Spider-Man these
are all going to be the leads of
Avengers Secret Wars some of the leaders
of this big Multiverse Avengers team so
what if the ending or possibly the
post-credit scene for Deadpool 3 is Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine and Deadpool
realizing what is happening the whole
entire Multiverse is falling apart and
they have to save it that's kind of
going to be one of the plots a subplot
of Deadpool 3 eventually they are going
to realize that the Multiverse is
collapsing and incursions are happening
and that's how they see a lot of these
other characters so perhaps by the end
of the film they realize that it's going
to be up to them and some other pretty
awesome Heroes to stop this and take
down Kang and the great thing about
Deadpool is one of the reasons we
absolutely love him is he can break the
fourth wall so I can defin definitely
see how in one of these final scenes or
post credit for Deadpool 3 he would say
Hey you know who else is an original
gangster and OG the movie that came
after the first X-Men film Spider-Man
Toby Maguire Spider-Man specifically
let's go get him he could definitely
help in this fight against King the
Conqueror I can even imagine a scene
where Hugh Jackman is looking at
Deadpool and going all right well who
else do we get who should join us and
Deadpool even goes It's Pizza time then
they go and get Toby now what is
interesting is that the gift seems to
very much imply that his job as a pizza
delivery man is going to be somewhat
relevant to the scene and I'm assuming
that the Toby Maguire Spider-Man variant
that we saw in no way home was well into
his life at this point in time married
to MJ has his daughter Mayday and
probably isn't delivering pizzas at this
point in time in his life I mean he
wasn't in the movies that we finished
with Spider-Man 3 of course he was
working at The Daily Bugle so this might
and I say might because we don't know
for sure but this might imply that a pre
previous version of Peter Parker might
be taken from an earlier point in time
now again this is just speculation at
this point in time perhaps the pizza
time actually doesn't really mean
anything perhaps it's just something
that Deadpool says because it's related
to Toby Maguire Spider-Man which I hope
is the case because it would honestly be
pretty weird if they acted like the Toby
Maguire that they get to appear hasn't
even gone through the events of
Spider-Man 3 and the events of
Spider-Man no way home Etc but I do
think based off of what we kind of know
about Deadpool 3 that the final scene or
the post credit could be a setup for
Spider-Man joining the Multiverse
Avengers team and Avengers Secret Wars
but go ahead and let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below what do you think these insiders
are referring to and would you like if
what I stated in this video actually
happens let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like this video And subscribe stay up
to date on the MCU and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you are entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
woof